all right guys
bang bang i've got david here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
yeah thanks for having me on absolutely
let's jump right into your background
uh this is not your first rodeo so maybe
talk to us just a little bit about where
you grew up and what you did before you
got to cracking
yeah so my background is uh you know
like a lot of people in this space uh
kind of a cross section of a bunch of uh
disciplines and experiences that kind of
i'll say like were purposeful but really
just like were a series of like
fortunate uh accidents that that led me
to where i am um
you know grew up kind of like a math and
science guy in the dc area
uh but when i went out to college out in
berkeley um kind of only minored in
physics and and
studied actual uh political economy uh
and then went to law school uh where i
studied uh ip law
uh as well as corporate and securities
law um and so you kind of blend all
those disciplines together and uh
some might say that's kind of a nice
cross-section to prepare you for crypto
um but but quickly after i went into law
i started
uh practicing ip and then like i said
corporate securities working with
private equity and hedge funds who
actually
were invested in alternative investments
and kind of like strange ones things
like a diamond fund
things like an actual ip and licensing
fund and i got really interested in
these kind of esoteric assets
and the markets are you know trying to
be developed around them
which led me to kind of leave law and
try to be on the fintech and financial
services side which i've done for the
last
uh 15 years first at a company called
second market in new york which is
actually the predecessor company
to digital currency group or dcg second
market uh was a marketplace where we
were building
uh you know services and and venue
trading venues for
all sorts of weird and emerging asset
classes things like bankruptcy claims
auction rate securities when that market
froze up uh pre-ipo private company
security so
before facebook went public we'd be
selling their equity and that's the
market that i worked on ran operations
for
ultimately we spun that out and sold it
to uh nasdaq
now operates today as nasdaq private
market and that was right around the
time fortuitously that barry silbert and
i
and others there we're getting into
bitcoin and so the transition to dcg
started to take place and uh
barry had a series of personal angel and
vc investments
uh that got brought over to form what is
now dcg
uh the fixed income auction rate trading
guys became what is now genesis
and then i set up and ran greyscale
investments in the bitcoin investment
trust
uh which obviously um you know has been
a runaway success
providing a kind of a straightforward
etf like
uh structure for for getting access to
bitcoin exposure
i got that listed on the otcqx raised a
couple hundred million dollars which
obviously
due to further fundraises and and the
price appreciation is now in the
billions um
but then uh joined fidelity investments
thereafter uh they approached me and uh
we're looking for a digital asset guy
to kind of help them figure out their
strategy in the space work with their
executives obviously that has now
culminated in all the great work they're
doing there
um and at the fidelity i also served as
a co-portfolio manager of an internal
prop fund
with uh matt walsh and nick carter the
guys from castle island um and so spent
some good time there and then actually
the last two years before joining kraken
was at circle
another company in the space helping
them kind of restructure
and overhaul their business to kind of
re streamline it and build it around
usdc their stablecoin
and all their api services around it but
uh once that project was complete uh
fortuitously again uh i've known jesse
and the folks at kraken
and it's been one of the companies i've
admired for a long time so when this
spdi operator came up
opportunity came up i jumped at it i
think it's a massive opportunity for
kraken and the industry at large
you've done so much uh what is your
official title at kraken
does kraken even have titles first of
all that
i love jesse i love kraken but that's
that should be the first question are
there real titles that crack it
you know it's a valid question uh kraken
is unique in a lot of ways uh but people
do have titles uh
and uh i i joined you know as an md but
now um
now with the actual receiving of the
charter that we'll talk about
um you know i'll be just dedicated to
the actual bank that we're running and
i'm the ceo
of uh what we're tentatively calling
kraken financial uh still some internal
debate about it but that's the working
title for the bank
what can you say what the other names
potentially could be uh kraken bank love
to have a voter poll
between kraken financial and kraken bank
that's not very many options
yeah well hey look you don't want to
overwhelm them with choice i mean you
could have a write-in ballot if you want
i love that uh okay so as the ceo of
we'll go with
kraken financial for now uh let's just
talk about kind of
the news which is you guys have uh
received this
approval um maybe talk through
just what wyoming is doing that is so
special
uh and kind of like what went into
setting up the opportunity for you guys
to actually apply
and get this approval yeah totally so
yeah as you referenced last week on
wednesday
um we received our charter to become a
special purpose depository institution
or spdi
which is the very specific type of bank
that we're becoming um and it's a very
attractive framework for a lot of
different reasons that that we'll go
into but um
there's no shortage of work uh that's a
it's a culmination of a lot of efforts
and
in another way a commencement of a lot
more effort uh but
the kraken team for well over a year has
been working with
stakeholders across wyoming at the
legislature the governor's office uh the
relevant agency at the wyoming division
of banking
and others in the ecosystem like caitlyn
long to help
build this regulatory framework and
you know right size it and tailor it to
the type of digital asset operations and
the type of oversight that we think is
most appropriate
uh so a ton of work went in uh in
earnest uh we we submitted our
application uh
in q1 and the q1 beginning of q2 and
then had a public hearing in august
which um
you know hundreds and hundreds maybe a
thousand pages uh that application a
document
was comprised of and then we had to
present in front of the banking board
uh and then they deliberated and
ultimately decided to give us the
charter
um and as i said in some ways this is a
commencement uh because we still have to
now approach the fed get our fed master
account or other domestic correspondent
banking relationships
get all you know operationalize
everything uh ahead of launch which
we're looking at q1
of next year for um so so it's been a
process but but it'll be exciting
got it and uh i saw the application
binder
uh i think it was marco santori took a
picture and tweeted it
and uh it looked like something your
teacher would plop down on your uh desk
in school and like you have to read this
and you'd be like i'm i'm going to drop
the class
like i mean this thing was really really
uh in depth what exactly goes into all
of that maybe talk a little bit just
about like what are they looking for you
guys to provide in that application
yeah i mean look they um their
obligation the state banking board in
particular is a government appointed
group
whose responsibility is uh to the state
of wyoming
is to take a look at the statutory
factors for granting charters
to banks and trusts and there's there's
a series of them you know
hey is this is this good uh is it did
the is this bank have a reasonable
likelihood of success
does the management and board uh have
these sufficient experience to to do
what they say they're going to do
is this going to benefit the local
citizens uh can we
ensure the safety and soundness of the
organization and customer protection
things like that and so all the
materials that they want to take a look
at and due diligence on those factors
we need to provide and that includes a
basic application but
a pretty robust business plan that was
you know 150 200 pages
financial projections that accompany it
and then all of the uh kind of drafted
programs and policies and procedures uh
on the compliance side and the security
side
and the internal control side uh we
drafted all of that stuff to
and corporate governance side and they
took a look at all of it uh to to make
sure that they weren't uh just approving
anybody out here
so it took uh quite a bit of work um and
that's how you know uh
you know we're we're qualified is that
number of pages kind of like a real life
proof of work
i love that uh so let's talk about these
spdis
uh what exactly is that what does that
mean
what can you do what can you not do um
and just kind of give us a summary of
for the the non-banking experts like
what this actually means
yeah as i said uh we're a bank but it's
a very specific type of bank
uh probably the closest analogous
institution is like a custody bank or a
depository institution of another kind
it's very specific as i said it was
built from the ground up
to kind of have certain features that
were very forward-looking and digital
asset centric
um and so there's two components to it
one on the usd or national currency side
it is a full reserve institution meaning
that uh we take customer deposits
and we maintain 100 uh you know
coverage on those we don't uh conduct
fractional reserves
or any rehydration or associated lending
activities
uh that gives rise to some of the
insolvency risks of traditional
uh customer facing and loan making bank
so that's an important feature here
and the benefit of that is a trade-off
right we can't do that and we can't make
money on that which is how a lot of
banks make money but on the other hand
uh that allows us to avoid duplicative
oversight from the fdic
and certain restrictions around the bank
holding company act and so
it's a real trade-off there because the
type of risks
that the fbi see and these things are
meant to uh guard against are that type
of insolvency risk that stem from the
activities
we cannot conduct on the other side the
digital asset side
they built a pretty unique framework
here that takes advantage of
existing legal concepts like bailments
to kind of
codify the relationship between
depositor and the institution
when they give you their digital assets
they uh harmonized it with the
underlying commercial code and
they have a dedicated supervisory
program that says hey here's what's
required
uh to run this and here's how we're
going to oversee you
and examine you and audit you uh that
doesn't exist
anywhere else in the country um so even
though you see others pursuing different
types of
uh charters or your trusts or bank
charters
they don't know uh they don't have it
codified exactly how the
examination process or oversight will
work uh so for those reasons it was a
very attractive framework and a
right-sized and reasonable one
uh kraken you know this isn't regulation
just for regulation's sake
this is regulation that allows allows
for this new type of business
to run uh while still mitigating the
risks that the real risks that it faces
got it and so would it be fair to say
that this is basically
a banking uh charter that allows you to
merge the legacy type bank with fiat
currency with a digital bank
um and solves for very specific
differences not only at one and kind of
the federal regulatory level or
insurance like fdic
uh but also when it comes to these
digital currencies looking at things
that are
native to digital currencies in terms of
everything from storage relationship
security
uh et cetera and it's really trying to
solve that problem is that fair
yeah yeah i think you've hit a lot of
the nails on the head there i mean
kraken's mission has always been
to promote the adoption of digital
assets uh to enable more individual
financial freedom across the world um
kraken financial is a key tool in in
doing that because it allows us to
seamlessly integrate
the existing financial system with
digital assets
uh and you're correct that uh the
framework that i talked about spells out
uh very specific rules around how to
operate in order to maintain the safe
safety and soundness of the institution
and customer protection rules around
how you should be storing digital assets
and what your it and is
program should look like what your
internal control structure should look
like things like that
and it's important to note too that as a
state chartered banks the interpreter
banks are given all the same powers
as federally or nationally chartered
banks here and so we do expect to pursue
a more consolidated coverage a
regulatory coverage model here
rather than you know trying to get 50
mtls
money transmission licenses which by the
way wouldn't give us direct access to
uh banking infrastructure in the federal
payment system anyways
got it and so what can you not do right
it sounds like you got to have kind of
100
reserves but what else can you not do uh
as part of this uh this charter yeah so
i mean that's the big one the big one is
that we're not taking customer deposits
and then
you know lending them out on the back
end in the loan portfolio that
the customer you know has no way of
knowing what's in there or you know
assess its risk and
has that kind of insolvency risk so
that's that's definitely the big one
um on the other side of like what else
we cannot do
there's certain components about lending
even on the digital asset side there's
restrictions there as well
everything there again was designed to
ensure that this was
able to speak to the type of digital
asset operations we have
while mitigating the type of insolvency
risks that a traditional bank faces
and so anything that um puts our capital
at risk
um and could lead to insolvency or
bankruptcy uh they put provisions in
there uh to kind of curtail that
got it and then from a serving the
customer standpoint is this
available to anyone in the world
anywhere in the united states just in
wyoming
how do you think about kind of uh
addressable market from a customer-based
standpoint
yeah i mean so so to start we're going
to be focused on um
us customers specifically existing
cracking customers um
you know kraken is pursuing this uh to
cover three objectives
one is the regulatory one i discussed we
think this is like a right-sized
tailored approach with consolidated
coverage uh the second one is the
infrastructure part i talked about
getting access to the federal payment
system and being able to integrate that
more seamlessly
into our product sets and customer
experiences and then third one is
an entirely new uh product uh and
distribution platform we can do things
that banks can do that non-banks can't
and so
to start with uh it won't change much
for the customer frankly speaking we'll
on the back end just have a different
kind of licensure structure
and we'll start to move over more of the
infrastructure to the bank
the kind of second phase will be that
this bank will take over the actual
customer
facing operations and be that kind of
portal
uh for all u.s customers that kraken
serves in the u.s
um from there two things will happen one
uh we'll look to
whether we could expand internationally
we do expect to be able to do that
tbd whether that means we'll serve
customers directly internationally
or simply serve other affiliated kraken
entities who'll pass that on to their
customers
and then the second prong of that third
phase is that we'll be able to start
launching new products
things like uh you know we'll be able to
launch debit cards and payment services
maybe backed by digital assets
things like ira accounts or trust uh
accounts
that can hold digital assets uh things
like wealth management services things
like
qualified custody for institutions or a
good control location for broker dealers
and then notably we can also handle
different types of assets securities
commodities
things that a normal custodial or
depository bank could do
and so customers in that third face will
start to see a host of new features and
products
got it and so as you think through this
um
will this require every crypto company
to become a bank
right or and is that kind of where we're
headed with these occ
uh type clarifications and things like
that or just kind of how do you view
uh maybe the other large incumbent
crypto companies and what the impact on
them could be from this yeah definitely
so
um i do like look if you're dealing with
crypto and the more crypto becomes
you know like financial services and
money um they're going to impose the
existing or or
analogous regulation on it we've always
understood that um
so whether it's you know a money
transmission license or some other else
some framework will be required for much
of the the activities here
i do think that that banking um will
massively grow over the next three years
in terms of crypto companies becoming
banks
uh and uh banks in in crypto activities
um i think that for a number of reasons
one look banking there's a lot of like
different types of regulatory regimes
for
securities and broker dealers under sec
and finra you know commodities
derivatives under cftc
banking is the granddaddy of them all to
steal like a rose bowl term
it is the bottom of the financial
services stack and is the thing that
everything relies on
in many ways and so it gives you um kind
of the broadest access the broadest
coverage
and uh allows you to do a lot more than
you could otherwise do
now with their become that you know
along with that comes with great
responsibility to be a good steward
of the federal payment system and all of
that so only at first i would imagine
the largest crypto companies pursuing
this it's not
easy to do i would also expect uh new
types of regulatory frameworks to follow
wyoming's lead
whether it's at the state or national
level i think these agencies are going
to borrow pretty liberally
from this framework you mentioned the
occ guidance and interpretive letters
a couple weeks back um i think july 22nd
they issued the uh
the letter about banks being able to
custody or deal with digital assets
um more recently i think this week they
said you know banks can bank stable coin
issuers
um which is great like i think those
things could have been done already it's
always been my understanding
that that was legally permissible but it
means something to have it written down
especially if you're a big incumbent
institution and have executives have
risk on their mind
this helps with that now they still have
a long way to go in terms of developing
an actual supervisory program and manual
harmonizing with the commercial code
these factors that wyoming already has
in place so
they're a little bit behind there but i
think all these agencies are going to
kind of develop something analogous
so again i'm not an expert in this but
uh
if wyoming has kind of state uh centric
legislation uh you could see other
states i guess
kind of incorporate or come up with
their own versions of it uh
is there a um either threat or an
opportunity from a federal level if they
just say hey you know what that looks
great like a great framework we're
actually just going to apply that at the
federal level
uh and then basically every crypto
company could be a
federally chartered like banking
institution
using this framework on a federal level
or like how does that work if
you know basically somebody comes in
over the top of wyoming basically with
different regulation
yeah no it's like so many things in
crypto crypto like kind of
forces the issue on these types of like
weird things you wouldn't think have to
do like this is like constitutional law
state versus federal stuff
uh it's pretty interesting to see and
even outside of um
crypto you're seeing this in the fintech
world and traditional financial services
um and you're seeing the convergence of
all three of these worlds digital assets
fintech
traditional financial services and the
regulators are following suit so as i
mentioned before
state chartered banks and federally or
nationally chartered banks
have the same powers now the the nuance
there is that when you're a state term
bank
generally you get recognition and
reciprocity across state lines
in your peer states um there's some
nuance there
uh especially here where other states
have very crypto specific verbiage and
laws
one example is new york with a bit
license you'd expect to have to jump
through a couple more hoops
to re-enter in new york there but at the
federal level there's federal preemption
and so that issue uh is much more
settled so that would be the one benefit
if that does happen and you're right to
say that there's a both a threatening
opportunity i view it as an opportunity
because it's a
competitive landscape which forces state
by state and
versus federal to kind of up their game
and so i would expect um and you're
seeing the occ kind of lean this way
uh federal regulators to do the same now
whether uh
it should be governed by the state or
the federal government is certainly uh
beyond my pay grade got it and so when
you think about
uh kind of the impact we talked about
crypto companies what about the
large uh incumbent banks or financial
service providers who
uh historically have had nothing to do
with crypto does this uh provide a
pathway for them to go pursue
uh maybe the occ thing is more impactful
like just how do you see the reaction
from the incumbents
yeah so as i said before um i think that
the occ letter
it's not rule-making it's not
legislation it's an interpretive
guidance and and saying what
me and many others have already
understood to be the case that they
could do this but
as i said it really does matter from
like a risk framework
when you're a big incumbent institution
you're saying well our existing business
is this big
this crypto market currently is is this
big right
um and the risk is x y and z
uh this helps at least on the risk side
and so uh it does help there
from an institutional level but also a
personal and individual level they're
real people
in the boardrooms and the executive
levels making this decision
uh whoever has to make the decision
wants something like that in their hand
to say like look it's okay um and they
you also needs a leader there
to be able to push things forward like i
said i was at fidelity fidelity is
perfectly positioned in terms of
incumbents to do this stuff because
one it has a a ceo and chairwoman who
personally is invested in this
obviously it's like a private uh family
by and large family owned and run
business
so it has more leeway than a public
company might
but others in the space seeing
fidelities of the world seeing
this type of legislation or rule making
or
guidance come out it absolutely helps
and kind of helps
get away with the uh ibgybg problem the
i'll be gone you'll be gone problems a
lot of executives sit here and say
crypto's not gonna be a thing for five
ten years we're all older we're gonna be
retired by then i don't care right and
so it's really risk averse
this at least helps mitigate that got it
in in terms of um the fidelities of the
world
it seems like there are a number of
institutions that are kind of crypto
friendly or crypto forward thinking um
is there a a worry that uh
this banking charter whether it's at
wyoming federal or other states
just becomes a resource game and
therefore like the
legacy incumbents just have more
resources and therefore kind of
beat all the crypto companies to the
punch and it's almost like uh
regulatory arbitrage or like a
regulatory mode to some degree
yeah yeah regulatory capture something
yeah look we see that
this is not like unique to this like you
see it in tech with facebook and these
other things
all the other big they want more
regulation because it it stops
smaller competitors in some ways right
um that that may be the case i will say
though um
what has happened here again is a more
streamlined
right-sized you know reasonable
regulation and so
uh it is meant to allow folks who are
besides but kraken or potentially even
smaller
to kind of participate in this in this
banking uh style game
um if you had a full-fledged bank that
would require even more assets so
if anything given where we are today
this helps the other direction if
anything
um i would also point out that um
there's also the idea that you know
banking
or financial services is a stack and so
to the extent that you know banking
is uh you know at the bottom of the
stack and there's bankers banks and
enterprise kind of bank software and
stuff
that will be able to enable smaller
companies to build on top and then kind
of you have the kind of
where on the stack uh do they expand to
the bottom go up or does the top go down
um at least it enables that to happen so
in my mind it's a good thing
got it and uh because it's in wyoming
uh you have to build the company in
wyoming uh talk a little bit just about
internally how you guys have thought
about you know subsidiary
standalone company what the relationship
between the the kraken financial crack
and bank is to to
kind of legacy cracking um and then from
a team perspective
uh you've got a bunch of pitchers
sitting on the wall behind you so i'm
assuming you're either
coming or going and kind of explain that
a little bit yeah yeah no i'm sitting
here in wyoming now
loving it i did recently relocate here
um you know
we built this structure um kraken
financial is a subsidiary
of cracking the broader cracking group
of companies but
because it is a bank uh it needs uh
independent governance and
and management and operations uh unlike
a traditional subsidiary so we have our
own
board of directors independent board of
directors we have you know management
that is dedicated to this actual entity
uh we have our own balance sheet our own
you know everything there
um so while we obviously kind of are are
bankrolled so to speak and supported by
kraken and
share similar visions and missions and
objectives we are in many ways an
independent company
um that said uh you know one of the
things that comes along with that is
this kind of like wyoming footprint that
we expect to have as i said
i recently recently relocated uh from
new york city we've been living there
for
15 years uh though you know i've been
all over the country so
pretty versatile luckily uh but i'm
seeing that path from new york to
wyoming
happen more and more um in many ways
they're very different many ways they're
very similar
uh from like look i went to new york i
was attracted to it because of freedom
right i mean like you could
be who you are do what you want when you
want why don't we kind of share some of
the same principles a lot other
differences of course
uh but but uh but it's great so we're
building an office here
um currently in slated for cheyenne uh
which is a great region to be in uh
that's where the state capital is
so we can work with our regulators and
division of banking
we can talk to the legislature uh we
have access to the university of wyoming
down the road here
and it's part of like the corridor north
of denver which obviously is a growing
and budding tech scene and of itself
so we'll build build an office here
expect to have 10 to 25 heads in the
first year
we expect to kind of build a lot of
operations here support
the local ecosystem which is obviously a
lot of the motivation and impetus
for wyoming in creating this is a jobs
economy
a diversification play and so we already
are
and have been sponsoring hackathons
conferences supporting the local
talent pipeline out of wyoming uh
bringing more people
uh here for our company events in fact
the broader
organization is looking at a
company-wide relocation program
and even considering uh redomiciling
it's corporate uh
entity and headquarters here um so so
we're committed we've found great
partners here i think it's a great place
to do business
uh little known fact next to delaware
the the next biggest state where the
most companies are domiciled
wyoming really i did not know that yeah
awesome what um what are the roles that
you guys are going to be hiring for so
if anyone's listening to this and uh
and wants to dm me on twitter they don't
have to and they can simply go and find
out where they can get a job with you
guys
yeah no appreciate that we're always
looking for good folks so we're looking
to fill out the uh the c-suite uh with a
cco chief compliance officer and chief
financial officer
um and then from there move down into
the other
managerial roles of the operational
operations finance
and compliance departments and then on
to more junior kind of like staff level
roles so
definitely going to be hiring a ton here
and always interested in talking to
quality candidates
where uh is the website the same as just
going to kraken.com or
should they go to like kraken financial
yeah so the we we leverage the same kind
of job site as kraken
right now uh we'll probably have a
landing page at some point soon
of our own uh but for right now yeah
tracking.com
got it uh what's been the biggest
surprise during this entire process
uh you know if i talked to you four
years ago i doubt you thought that you
were going to be the ceo of a bank
sitting in wyoming
uh just what that process that to kind
of getting here what
what is that surprise been yeah i mean
maybe it's full circle i was born in el
paso which is
just down i-25 uh i mean number of hours
but uh
kind of maybe i'm returning home once
once you drink from the rio grande you
always come back they say so
uh it's kind of like a homecoming here
out west um yeah i know so
a number of things right um i i look
back at my career and be like oh it all
ties together neatly obviously you like
make things up in your head
we're all sense making machines as
humans um but but realistically when i
look at this
um i think you're seeing the dispersion
and distribution of financial centers
in the financial game all over the world
uh you know coming having lived in new
york for the past 15
or so years um outside of a soldier in
boston
you know it's it's very interesting to
see because you think of you know
new york london singapore as these
financial capitals um
that's starting to distribute a little
bit more same thing is happening
obviously with tech
a very similar story there um maybe it's
exaggerated it on twitter by a lot of
people
everyone's moving out of the cities it's
like talk to me when a 20-something
who's single moves out of new york or
san fran right
but but in any event um a couple things
have surprised me in this process one
um the wyoming folks have been
incredibly savvy
they've done their homework uh much more
so than any other regulator or agency
that i've ever
encountered um in my life um they've
kind of fought this from the ground up
they've done the work to get smart on
digital assets they've done the work to
harmonize this
with their peers in other states and at
the federal levels and they're really
looking to build something here
with the support of the legislature and
the governor's office um so that's
really surprised me
just how savvy and far ahead of the game
they were um the other thing here
that's really surprising to me is just
how many uh since the announcement last
week we started to become a little bit
more public about it
just how many and the types of
organizations
uh that we've been uh talking to that
have been inbound and
the same thing i saw when we were trying
to sell the bitcoin investment trust
back in 2013
i mean you'd go into city or whatever
institutional investor and pitch it to
them i mean the heads would [ __ ]
you know the eyes would squint up it's
like what are you what are you talking
about
um and in some ways that's still the
same when you're talking about banking
relationships in the digital asset
industry
but the amount of like partners who want
to be our correspondent banking partner
who want to
build on top of what we're building and
the names
has been really accelerated from what i
thought it would be
that's awesome uh before i get into the
rapid fire questions to wrap this up
i got one question jesse's been on once
or twice i can't remember
uh what's the best and worst thing about
working with jesse
uh it's interesting so uh let's see here
he's gotta be careful look at him look
at him
look at me screaming in my chair here
you got me all nervous hot around the
collar
no jesse's like jesse's great and like
look i've been ingested before this and
you know i've admired him for a long
time um i love the way that like
he has and this is reflected in kraken
it's like the customer-centric and
willing to challenge
and take a stand on things that um in
the near term it'd be easy to roll over
on
and say like look let's just go path of
least resistance or whatever but if it
doesn't align with our mission our
values and in fact
at the end what we believe to be in the
best interest of the customer
he fights for that um quite a bit uh he
also like obviously thinks of the box
and carefully considers things from a
very different perspective for sure
obviously uh i think i i don't forget
who said this but
if you work for a company whose ceo
isn't at least a little bit intense
like move to a different company you
know what i mean and so jesse has a
great engine on him he's always thinking
he's always trying to
get involved uh which is tremendous um
but what you're also seeing at the same
time
is kraken and jesse go through this
maturation process of building this kind
of like
uh very kind of financial corporate
company that that expands the across the
globe and
in order to kind of take that next leg
up and so it's been a tremendous thing
to watch
it uh it is fascinating to me to see
somebody who has built you know one of
the great crypto companies and kind of
really
uh you know been at the tip of the spear
of innovation and kind of push the pace
uh of growth then have to go deal with
uh
regulators politicians banks like
the the the uh the clashing of styles
there has to be a
an absolute uh thing to see yeah yeah i
know i mean like he's he has his
own style but people appreciate uh
authenticity which he certainly is
and people appreciate you know straight
shooters and new ways of thought
um you know it's shocking and it's great
to see him you know you see him on
twitter he has opinions he puts himself
out there
um it's very most financial services
company executives just said
it's easier if i just don't have an
opinion right um so it's great to see
that absolutely uh before i wrap up
two questions then you get to ask me one
first one is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
oh the most important book that i have
ever read
slaughterhouse five kurt vonnegut why
uh i think it like brought a very unique
perspective to you know
you're talking about world war one two
in history
um kind of like it from a very specific
perspective the perspective that he
brought on it
um was very different very humanizing
very individual in nature
and i think it kind of um underbelies a
lot of what i see today and like you
know in the media
um you know or else wherever you know a
lot of different perspectives
uh truth is a very elusive and hard
thing um and i think it's been
instructive
love that answer uh second one's more
fun aliens believer or non-believer
oh you know what i love a good
like i'm specific about it but i love
conspiracy theories like very specific
ones
uh so absolutely a believer my favorite
one though
uh is the moon landing like are you
telling me that the united states went
to the moon in the 60s
and literally no one has ever set foot
again on it let's see
all right you ready so uh i used to joke
all the time and say you're telling me
they were live streaming from the moon
but i can't get sunday football
to live stream correctly right you know
in 2020
but somebody corrected me i did not know
this we've gone
four times it was all within a span of i
think like four or five years
uh but then we never went back so and no
one else has are you telling me that
russia or china wouldn't be like we can
do that right
it seems odd to me i don't know i'm just
saying so what what what are the
probabilities do you think it's more
probable that we didn't go to the moon
or more probable that aliens exist
oh man let's see all my guys who are
like actual like bayesian like risk guys
and stuff
will hammer me on this for sure uh like
i think from a uh it's probably more
it's more probable
that it's more probable that there are
aliens just in the grand scheme of
things that there's everything
right probably is what i would say
that's a fair answer all right you could
ask me one question to finish up what do
you got for me
what color would you say your eyes are
color of my eyes
yeah oh they're blue the screen screws
you don't get more nuance than that
they're kind of green too you know just
what do you but more seriously though
um like beyond uh like the financial
services or whatever uh here in
the crypto space outside of like
traditional financial services and
regulatory stuff
what are you like most excited about
here uh well
i'm cheating because i just revealed
everything yesterday
uh one of my partners and i jason uh
we've been uh buying a bunch of digital
art and basically the thought process
is if you if you take gold and bitcoin
you put them next to each other like
bitcoin's superior in every way
right and then if you take traditional
art and digital art and you put them
next to each other
digital artists um superior in every way
and so i think like
exactly what you're talking about in
2013 you'd be like what the hell is that
right uh that's about to play out all
over again with digital art compared to
this traditional art
um and what becomes interesting to me is
like
you not only are going to get a better
user experience like i just hang a
screen on my wall and it can change
that's motion there can be noise like
all that kind of stuff uh with just the
art itself but then also you start to
look at like
you know the traditional art world is
heavily heavily manipulated
right it's all like okay everyone come
together in this one room and then we're
gonna auction something off and like
we've done all this marketing and
it's like wait what like now there's
just the internet right you just put
things up and anyone with an internet
connection can like have access to it
um so i think that like that's probably
one big area uh
and then the second area that i find
absolutely fascinating
um is this idea of like
complete decentralization
uh of like an organization
so kind of like the dow was kind of like
a like like an attempt uh i don't think
we're anywhere near
like a legitimate shot again uh
but i do find it very fascinating if you
can basically
you know imagine if you could have an uh
organization where
there was no leadership and all the
decisions were made by
like driving consensus like that's super
interesting uh
again i don't want to be a part of any
of it i don't want to like
risk any capital there yet like we're
just nowhere near being able to do that
but i think like that
general train of thought is fascinating
yeah yeah we're early there but it is
amazing like think of coast theorem as
transaction costs get lower
firms kind of dissolve into like uh the
world i mean it'll it'll be really
fascinating for sure
i don't want to say what company it is
but i saw one company
that they basically had taken their cap
table and they had put it on the
bitcoin network like they basically were
like tokenizing it on the bitcoin
network and i don't understand all the
technical details
uh but i was talking about like making a
potential investment they started
talking i was like wait what like
there's no organizat and you just saw
like yeah that's where the world's going
right and uh it may not happen for a
while but at some point it's definitely
gonna happen
i know i love the space i mean look
there's so much stupid stuff happening
but like
who am i to say what's stupid uh like
the ability to like
try stuff is pretty unprecedented in
this world like there's gonna be some
uh some some spilled milk for sure uh
but but it's interesting
i talked to uh sam bankman freed from
ftx
and alameda research and uh he had a
great way to put it he basically said
uh if you're a capitalist you don't care
about what is stupid and what's not you
just care about how to make profits
and like and when you look at it through
that lens like okay
like that that's something that i think
wall street will get very excited about
right
it's like i love him and dan at cm do
you want to be right or do you want to
make money
which is it that's exactly right all
right david where can people find you on
the internet and find out more about
uh kraken financial yeah so go to
kraken.com i mean
if you're an existing customer expect to
hear more from us soon if you're not
sign up for kraken.com so you can get
access as early as possible
um and then you know at kanitsky
k-i-n-i-t-s-k-y
on twitter awesome man thank you so much
we'll have to do this again in the
future
yeah for sure